joining us this morning from Zurich is
someone who has been warning of a demise
in the US economy for some time said
that stocks would be off their November
highs from last year he has of course
none other than Mark Faber the editor
and publisher of the Gloom boom and doom
report and Mark uh you're joining us
from Zirk we might be uh you know here
in the markets overseas we might be a
little bit jittery today uh but I've got
to say markets have gone here in the US
in a complete opposite direction of what
you called for almost a year ago what
gives
Mark well uh we have to clarify the
statement I was expecting a correction
for now 2 years I think we've gone up in
a straight line from October 2011 up to
here we're three years into this bull
market where we didn't have more than a
10%
correction and uh this year has been
irregular so some in indices like the
SNP are up a modest
6% and the uh Russell 2000 is down
4% uh 50% of shares on NASDAQ are down
uh 20% or more from their recent high in
Asia we had markets like uh the
Philippines Indonesia Vietnam India
Thailand Pakistan that are all up
between 20% and
28% right so when people tell me that
the S&P has been such a great place to
be I have to laugh because emerging
markets in Asia at least have done
fantastically well uh relative
relatively speaking yes they haven't
performed as well as some of those other
markets uh you're talking about by the
way yes and by the
way last fall I was interviewed and I
said I thought that at the time treasury
notes yielding 3% would be an
interesting investment and the yield has
fallen to below
2.5% and the dollar has been strong so I
don't know what you're complaining
about what do you mean you don't know
what I'm complaining about hang on hang
on one second Mark well you you make
sound as if I'm wrong about everything I
rejected Mark hang on one second though
because we do have breaking news we have
ADP employment data
213,000 jobs uh were created in the
month of September that is a little bit
better Mark than what we saw uh that
what Economist had expected at
25,000 jobs so 213,000 jobs all of this
leading up of course to the Friday labor
report but Mark okay so getting back to
your point let me talk about this then
uh the US economy though has been
continued to be to be recovering not as
much as some have said right uh you've
said before that the economy you believe
is sliding the global economy in fact is
sliding into a recession and we haven't
seen that and we have seen yields come
down we haven't seen gold uh in fact
rally to the points that you have
mentioned before
Mark yes I always said that uh people
should own some physical gold and store
it out outside the United States this is
an insurance policy that will pay off
one time uh big in future I don't know
when I don't care when but it is a a
safe investment and it's an insurance
and part of a total portfolio that
consists of equities bonds and cash real
estate and precious metals number two
concerning the global economy I was
talking in particular about about uh the
emerging economies and the Chinese
economy and I was H saying a year ago
already that in my view the Chinese
economy had slowed down to gross rate of
4% now recently the economic statistics
that were released electricity
consumption down year on year railroad
Freight traffic down year on year the
Shanghai government uh reported
industrial production down year on year
and exports down year on year and the
other Asian economies to which I travel
are mostly flat no more grow there's one
country I went recently which is a Boom
Town it's
Cambodia that is a boom town because
it's become a huge laundry
shop uh and you are seeing of course the
shine taken off of of the markets in
China particularly in light of these
Hong Kong protest but I want to get back
Mark though uh to the US markets here uh
which you have said which you just said
a few moments ago uh we haven't gotten
that correction uh in the US markets
that you were looking for uh that in
fact it has underperformed the markets
overseas but it is still in a bull year
it is still in the fifth year of its
Bull Run so at some point do you expect
that that run is going to end as you
predicted back in
November yeah yes correct I think uh a
most people haven't made that much money
in US Stocks this year some hedge funds
have made some money and others have
lost some money it's been for many hedge
funds a difficult
environment and usually when you have US
dollar strengths it means it's a sign or
a symptom of tightening Global liquidity
which usually hasn't been particularly
good for US Stocks now if I look look
around the world US stocks are very
pricey compared to other shares around
the world maybe they'll go up a little
bit more like in 87 or before March 2000
and then they'll drop a lot but in
general if you take the view of the next
7 to 10 years I think you'll make more
money in emerging economies whereby near
term I think that all markets are
vulnerable all of them Mark you also
said though that you thought some tech
stocks were pretty pricey as well right
the Facebooks and the Twitter and the
Teslas and in fact correct uh they
haven't been good shorts if you did
short those stocks they've all actually
except with the exception of Twitter
have risen even more to record
highs yes correct you're
right so what happened there so do you
think they're better value you think
they're better value now that they're up
I Vis the time that I thought they're
already overpriced it's like if we had
this interview in March 2000 and you
would tell me Well in December 99 you
said uh tech stocks were expensive and
here they're up another 30% and I will
tell you yes they up another 30% and
then they'll drop 70% so what are
investors missing then what are they
Facebooks I what are investors missing I
recommend to you I I recommend to you as
a friend go and buy Facebook and apple
and Netflix and Twitter and all these
talks right and then I'll lose my shirt
is that what you're saying and then you
will see how much money you've made